[Musik]
ich wurde am 22 getestet da kamen dann
drei tage später das positive bescheid
es sind viele menschen wegen mir in
quarantäne gegangen die in kliniken die
in kindergarten der betreuung machen
müssen alles seinen weg gegangen und
auch immer am letzten tag der quarantäne
am zweiten viertel wurde auf ihr telefon
nicht mitgeteilt es stimmt alles nie sie
sind negativ was wollen sie von uns
[Musik]
ich brauchte diesen zwei test der zweite
musste aber bei mir zu hause erfolgen
weil ich im moment keinen führerschein
und das hat man mir verweigert
dann habe ich ans landratsamt bis zu 32
mal am tag telefoniert dass ich einfach
schriftlich das brauche dass ich negativ
bin dann hätte mich auch jeder fahren
können und den auf dem wollte ich bis
heute noch
[Musik]